hi guess what viewers it's kevin van
orden i am sitting next to chris wilson
how are you good thanks and Chris you're
with grinding Gear games that's right
yep and you are here to show us the
long-awaited expansion to path of Exile
that's right it's called sacrifice of
the valley go and I am anxious to see
what this is all about of course path of
exile was gamespot's pc game of the year
and one of our nominees for overall game
of the year so inc you very my hope that
was good exciting for you guys the chain
was so excited to hear we had a party it
was good you had a party just for that
yeah well that's awesome you know
Christmas time did invite us I got no
invite I would come hold X New Zealand
but possibly you never know um but
obviously here you're here to show us
the expansion so you why don't we just
jump right in because we've got it right
here on the screen and tell us about
what character you're bringing in and
how you're going to be approaching all
of this so I'm playing a duelist at the
moment and the first thing to know about
sacrifice of the val is the expansion
content has been weaved throughout path
of Exile we haven't just dump it all on
the endgame we've made sure to throw it
in very early areas and as you'll see as
I play through this area on the ship
graveyard well actually see some the new
content so the basic idea behind
sacrifice of the vowel is that the vowel
civilization who have been dormant for
2,000 years have finally returned and
queen at ze the queen of the vowel has
come back and started influencing right
last and if I follow the coast up this
way you'll see such a good example of
the kind of thing that she's done to
corrupt various areas of the game now do
you suppose this is a good reason for
people to start in in in a new league
start a new game plus what do you think
is that there's pretty much me here for
everybody absolutely yeah we are
launching new leagues with the expansion
and i'll be talking in detail about the
features that they have so it's a great
time to dive back in or to try to gain
me through a new player this side area
here is an area that you wouldn't
normally come across some path of Exile
it has a red beating heart outside and
ominous sounds and streams of blood
flying through the air so this is
essentially a corrupted side area and
these are scattered throughout the game
approximately once per hour of
gameplay roughly players will run into
them and the first thing you'll notice
when you have a look at it is that it
actually has mods on it this says n
combustible sunken jungle of stressors
so this is very much like an existing
magic item in the game where it has a
prefix isn't a prefix and suffix on it
in this case n combustible and off
stasis affects the mods on the area and
we're borrowing the mods from the map
system that we have for the endgame so
this is essentially baby's first map as
it were as players play through the game
they get the ability to see maps and
controlled situations and have a chance
of playing through door well it you know
as path of Exile stands now maps or
something that it takes a bit of you
know a bit of time for people to really
take advantage of them right so this is
a way of getting that getting that idea
across early on certainly yeah you'll
play through quite a few of these before
you get to the end game so you'll have a
good idea what the mods are and how they
affect areas I'll dive right into this
one so this is one of the vowel side
areas and as you can see it's got you
know red mist all over the ground and
very dangerous combinations of monsters
now my character here is relatively
overleveled because we've been letting
journalists play these characters this
week so we have to make sure they're
pretty powerful and so as you play
through this area the first thing you'll
notice is the mods are affecting how
difficult it is so this particular area
has players of no life on my neighbor
generation and the 75% additional
monster fire resistance thankfully i'm
not doing fire damage to that particular
things have no mean no major issue to me
but if i was a fire focused character
this would be significantly harder for
me and i might have to come up with ways
to approach that I wouldn't have in the
past that's right and it's a good
opportunity to bring bring your friends
as well because these are relatively
hard to find now the thing we'll notice
here is there's actually a boss a unique
bosses attacking me so because all of
these sign areas need to have their own
unique boss encounters we've actually
added 16 new bosses to the game and
we've made sure that they use relatively
complicated skills for example you can
see this guy is casting blue storm calls
on the ground as they run around and at
some point those are going to go off and
if I'm anywhere near them is going to
hurt pretty badly and I need to get out
of the way so what their happens
basically and we've put a lot of effort
into making sure that the bosses use
complicated combinations of skills so
this particular guy is using both
multiple shots people throw
that strong pull effects such as
Victor's about to hurt me
oops of course this is this is a
following up from from things you've
already done in the game up at this
point I mean path of Exile is a is a
work in progress besides just the
upcoming expansion what are what are
some of the things you've done recently
22 to let people know so that if they've
if they've left path of Exile if they
haven't played for a while what's it
going to be like for the boat since
since the release on October we've added
a lot of patches to the game I believe
we did six major patches are between now
between now and then and they've added
quite a lot of new skills for example
the one point 06 patch that we released
our in January added four new summoning
skills the ability to raise corpses out
of the ground and a new way of summoning
minions are raging spirits I believe
their calls that could help you and this
is really popular the characters who
play summoners which is me which that
makes me happy because as a playing as a
witch with about 15 minions trailing
behind me yeah I don't know that edge
that that's that's that's good times yes
so now that I've killed the boss in this
area I have access to the valve vessel
which is basically the thing containing
the vile evilness that screw up to this
area and when I open it I get a random
violation in this case it's a fragment
of radiant dust now we're not revealing
quite what these fragments are used for
them sure the players will work it out
pretty quickly but you'll see here that
this fragment it's alyssa is a map-like
item juice the fact that it has a square
border a rectangular border around it
now it's also possible to find val skill
gems from these chests and typically a
player's more likely to find a vowel
skill gem than an actual fragment so I
was relatively lucky to find it there so
if you'd like I can demonstrate how the
vowel skills work by all means certainly
so i'll switch across to my other
character
so the Val civilization had skill gems
thousands of years before the players
currently do and their skill gems are
pretty different their skill jumps are
basically fueled by the sacrifice of
enemies and this means that the skill
isn't actually something you can use
right off the bat you have to kill a lot
of monsters before you can and this
actually plays well into what the
players have been asking for for a long
time they've been asking for Ultima
versions of skills you know the ability
to kill monsters for a while and charged
up and then decimate large groups at
once so we can demonstrate a few of
these so the skills I was just using
their a relatively simple vanilla path
of Exile skills so for example that's
arc it hits a couple of enemies as
relatively boring but the ultimate
version of arc is more interesting if I
just cheech to kill a bunch of enemies
as it were now when I use the Val
version of ugh you'll see that it
actually changed 40 times between the
monsters and shocks them so this is the
kind of thing you can save up and
occasionally use it to decimate a large
group similarly this is ice Nova it hits
and kills a bunch of monsters but the
Val version when used will actually
chain from one to another and i'll just
see if i can find a slightly larger
group of monsters to use it on it's much
more impressive when there's a big group
well it looks like this may be the
extent of the group we're getting there
we go you got a got a few stragglers
coming in so as you can see each of the
ice nervous will cause another icing
over on another monster now what kind of
limitations do you have on these types
of skills other are they do they just
have huge mana costs or do you have to
charge them up so before you can
actually let them let them go you see at
the bottom right on my screen here
there's a vial I sinova it's got a
little red area which gets larger as I
kill the monsters it gradually takes up
and that's basically the sacrifice of
the enemies souls that's pure opium so
periodically as you can see it's
relatively frequently in this particular
case I'm gonna be able to cast that
skill again so in this case a couple
wall monsters and now I have the ability
to do that so it's perhaps a little bit
of an offshoot of the way the game
already handles things like health and
mana in the sense that they they they
grow as you kill monsters certainly yeah
and it I mean that's what action RPGs
are about their about killing monsters
and secondarily about items so I have
another example of a skill that i can
use here if this here is the regular
spark skill then our current version
of the ultimate version of spark looks
like this spewing out a lot of spikes
now we're iterating heavily on these
skills before they're released next week
so it may look different on the final
version but that's where we're at
currently with that one it definitely
her this amazed the screen quite
effectively so I have another character
that has some more of our skills that I
can show you switch back to the Duelist
here and I'll just walk to a higher
level area to demonstrate them charge
them up with the cheat so this still
here that you've probably seen before is
cyclone and it's a relatively typical
skill and action RPGs it allows you to
fight the river monsters cutting them to
pieces sure so when we were designing
the ultimate version of cyclone we
wanted something that well that befit
the name ultimate so the ultimate
version of cyclo sucks in enemies from
off the screen pulling them to warm
white Italy only hit which one just
sliding in yeah I'll see if I can
nothing can escape your gravity yeah so
we're really pleased with that one and
the players are going to really love it
because it lets you suck in small chests
and stuff as well as if I can find
another cup of monsters that befits its
size ya think with random level
generation of course is that you get
some pacing in the areas where there are
quiet places and then very dense places
and in this case I'm running to require
one actually back to where I came from
but of course you need the quiet for the
for the exciting stuff to have car next
okay well I completely fail to find some
monsters there but I can't demonstrate
sucking these barrels in
you showed those barrels who is boss
yeah so it's meant to be used to kill 30
or three monsters at a time of course so
I'll just walk to another area so i'll
refresh this once we get some monsters
to fire the players are you know
scurrying to write down all the cheats
that just don't work on the live realm
of course good luck guys okay so the
next skill that I'd like to demonstrate
is our valve version of molten shell now
multan shell typically puts a shield on
you and when you've taken a certain
amount of damage it detonates hurting
the monsters nearby but the way that the
Val version works is basically they
can't so detonate every time your head
so now whenever these guys hit me it's
going to do so I can go and stand next
to them they'll eventually hit me and it
deals damage to them until they die so
this gives you you know 10 seconds or so
oh the ability to reflect quite a lot of
damage to the enemies I love that you're
just standing around no big whoop yeah
now enemies that to die while you're
using 1 one of these skills are you
actually charging up skills at the same
time that you're killing enemies using
those steps right yes so you could
potentially if you if you play your
cards right you could potentially get a
lot out of these things by just
maximizing how much damage you're doing
every time you have eight I'm sure if
you run through the level getting enough
monsters at once you get pretty close to
using a second instance of some of the
skills in fact some of them will charge
up multiple times you see I have a
counter at the bottom 0 and 0 they can
actually climb a more than one in some
cases let you back up a few of them if
you want to and we've tried to have some
variants where certain skills take less
skills than others so some of them you
can only use once per level because
they're so powerful and others are
relatively common like that ice nova so
there is another gameplay system that
I'd like to show absolutely if you have
me to go into the next one so the system
do with items now essentially when
you're trying to expand an RPG what you
really want to avoid doing is just
throwing a new tier of items right on
top of the end of the game because then
everyone's work that they put under
finding the existing items all for
nominated right yeah it kind of sucks
you're playing your favorite game and
then an expansion comes out and your
items that you've spent hours grinding
for I just kind of crap compared to the
new one but on the other hand you want
people to get the expansion to feel like
they're getting something new and
exciting and different right so how do
you what do you do to balance so
basically we ask the question
what can we do with the item system to
take it in another axis and we knew that
we want to play us to be able to get
items that are marginally better than
their current ones who would rather they
started with the current ones as a base
for that and to tie this into the
sacrifice of the vowel we've basically
introduced the vile orb now this is it
corrupts an item modifying it
unpredictably now the key thing about a
corrupted item like this one here is
that once it's been corrupted it can't
be further modified for example if I
take my if i take my orb of alchemy and
I try to alchemy that item it doesn't
work item is now locked in that state
now the first thing that a Verilog can
do is just corrupt the item so it hasn't
made the item any worse except for the
fact that effect except the fact that
it's now locked on stage so if you've
got your set of perfect items in your
character and you corrupt them all it's
not the end of the world you can still
continue to play but it's certainly not
the advantage you are hoping for if you
rolled unluckily thankfully there's some
very powerful things that corruption can
do for example these are some boots are
corrupted were added and implicit mod of
physical life leech on these boots now
players path of Exile will know you
can't typically get life leech on boots
especially not one percent which is
relatively high given the ratios of our
life and damage in the game so these
boots are now better their boots that
don't have this life leech and there's
no other way that boots can get it so
you get situations where if a user
really needs the smart for their build
they can now obtain it but they have to
risk quite a lot of their existing boots
to get a so how what do you think the
sort of the percentages of of the
possibility what is the possibility that
this is just going to do something
terrible and i will have used these orbs
for not or i will have ruin these so we
disputes for not i've got four examples
of different things yet i wake of
roughly bullying the players will
discover the intricacies so the first
chance is that it does nothing to the
item except corrupt it this is
absolutely a failure case the second
chance is that it modifies the implicit
model in the item to something that's
new and exciting and this is definitely
a success case it may not be the more
they want but someone else is probably
going to want to trade for us right the
third option here is that it rerolls the
item randomly so this item is being
rerolled and there are some interesting
ways that we reroll the item that can
make it actually easier to get certain
things players can't currently get so
this while it's a failure case adjust
rear older item there's certainly some
interesting side effects that will
happen occasionally that will make
players glad when it occurs and the
final case here is that the socket
became white now white sockets are not
previously possible to obtain
demand a path of Exile and what they
mean is that you can put any color of
gem there and this is very useful for
certain bills that want to use off-color
stuff for example on the summit of which
you were talking about maybe it's
difficult for her to get the the red and
green sockets that she might need to use
certain supports on her minions in her
armor and so because of this is a chance
that you can get white sockets however
because in both cases the item gets
corrupted it's not possible to get a
white socket and also an implicit mod
that you want you can never choose what
you're going for and this encourages
players to corrupt items of about medium
tier you don't want to waste your vile
ob's on corrupting junk that you may not
want to try to corrupt the best item on
the realm of the match you might want to
leave it in its tradable stage where I
don't mean to imply the corruption makes
it untradeable but it's certainly going
to be worth more in its pre corrupted
stage and knowing how player psychology
works so it really fits into the sort of
the path of Exile way any way in which
there's always you know there are great
rewards there for you but there are also
high risks to doing that and certain you
know certain advantage you don't know
what you're going to have what the
advantage is going to be until until all
is said and done a lot of the item
system is based around randomness and
this is like a small extra layer on top
that's used for perfecting items and it
actually applies to quite a lot of other
game systems other than pure items for
example this here is a corrupted file
right i took my level 25 bull gem and i
tried to use a vowel or bonnet and i got
a corrupted one which is no different
than my normal one is exactly the same
damage I could use it just like any
other fireball that currently exists in
path of Exile but if I'm really lucky I
can get something like this which has
level 21 in this case the maximum level
has actually been increased by the
corruption it's also possible to
decrease it this one here has quality
that's higher than 20 a small bonus but
in the right hands this actually makes
the gym quite a lot better now again you
have to choose between trying to go for
maximum level or trying to go for
maximum quality because you kind of both
and of course it's possible to corrupt
the item into a volume itself so if
you're lucky you might get the valve
version of a skill you're trying really
hard to find will there be methods of
undoing those for example there are
there are ways of undoing certain you
know certain things in path of Exile now
if you if you apply corruption is there
you know do corrupted items can you
still you know
take the gem away can you you know what
are some of the options if you don't
like the result we're not planning a way
to undo the corruption and the reason
here is because it's possible to get
things like this white socket that are
just amazingly good even better when
combined with other things like the n
plus of modern this item we want to make
sure that each of these in states is an
interstate and it actually promotes an
interesting thing in the crafting system
where you have difficult decisions about
at what point am I going to stop working
on this item and we found the best
results occur when you're trying to
craft items that aren't your best ones
it's a lot more rewarding because they
now suddenly become quite a lot better
when they get these corrupted stats on
them and some players are certainly
going to try leveling gems all the way
up to 20 then maxing the quality out
then having a shot to try to make it a
21 / 20 fireball or a 20 / 20 valve
viable and it's going to add a lot of
depth to the item system because
currently gem trading is rather shallow
you know some people trade some 20
quality gems some people trade some
high-level gems but they're certainly
not the depth of that system that there
are with the rest of the items and this
goes a long way towards making sure that
there is it's also possible to corrupt
maps which is another system entirely
valid nice work out how that works now
you're getting into some nitty-gritty
there do you has there been a point
where where you look at this and you
have to balance you know just how much
stuff people are going to want to hold
onto because if you're not even me a
reason to maybe hold on the items that
before I may not have kept for myself
where I may have traded you know now I'm
going to be tempted even more than
before two maybe hold on to some of
those mid tier or lower haight here
items that I might have sold before you
know is there are you you know do you
think this is giving people a reason to
hold on to more gear that they might
have not held on to the phone I'll play
us love pudding and we love so expensive
that's true but yeah it it certainly
means that you have to really evaluate
the items that you're finding and it
means there's more useless for items
which means that items are potentially
better as we pick them out rather than
just getting something as I'm not gonna
care about this i can find that it boots
elsewhere you're not thinking oh this is
a perfect corruption target it's
probably worthless but if I get lucky
with the corruption it's gonna be pretty
good whats max number of stash tabs
right now ah 65535 I think oh my god so
you did so you nobody's in any danger
anytime soon of running out of space his
way they might run
money before they run out of money burn
our space okay but but we've actually
served yeah we've actually observed
players buying quite a lot of stamps in
some cases which is cool other players
learn to control the number of items
they have a not store over a hundred
thousand nations I don't have a hundred
thousand item you have a lot but that's
certainly not that well the fact that
we're proud of is we've now head of a
half a billion items stored in a
database so that's way more than half a
billion items have drops these are the
ones that people have actually picked up
and chosen to keep right we're quite
proud of that stat now excellent so
you've also got some new leagues coming
and some other things why don't you tell
us about the show the rest that's a
perfect segue into the next topic I'm
very good at seg layers ok so we're
introducing new four-month leagues and
they're called ambush and invasion now
the rationale behind four-month leagues
and path of Exile is that they
introduced a whole of new exciting
there's exciting at the beginning when
the league's are fresh and you want to
dominate the ladder and get new items
before anyone else they're exciting in
the middle when your characters are
finally coming into their own and you're
getting that point we optimizing your
gear and they're exciting for the
traders on the end where there's
interesting bargains to be had
especially as the league's merge back
with the long term once and for those
who don't know the way it works as
there's these permanent long-term
leagues the hill characters are always
going to end up in so you're not losing
any progress it's not like we're wiping
the servers and that kind of thing but
there are challenged leaks that come out
every four months where you can opt to
play and about half the players choose
to and we love challenge leagues because
it's a good excuse for returning players
to say you know this new content and I'm
gonna get a fresh playing field with
everyone else so I'm not really losing
me and you know I'm not competing
against people I have a year's more
items than I do as long as they start in
the challenge leagues so it's a good
opportunity for new players to try the
game which any players to come back and
the experienced players love them as
well because it lets some show that
they're the best because they have the
experience of frontage but there's some
interesting stuff and the challenge
leagues and I'll just see if I can find
some of that stuff in this area so the
the league that I'm actually demoing in
at the moment is the ambush League and
hopefully we can find something
befitting of an ambush okay so here we
go this item here is a strongbox now it
says on it guarded by 10 monsters rather
than a normal chest this ambush only
chest will spawn 10 monsters when I open
it but wait it's unidentified does that
mean I can ID it it's got mods on it so
this particular chest is two hundred and
fifty percent increase quantity of items
so it's going to drop a lot of stuff and
it contains mirrored items which is
actually a maze
lucky because you know that's a very
rare one so what this means there's
every Asian that comes out as in a
duplicated form as well so you get two
copies of another sweet if it's GOT JUNK
I'm getting two copies of junk and if it
has some amazing stuff well that's going
to be with you know best day of play
it'll also has cast a random curse so
it's going to curse me when I open it
and cast lightning storm on me now
combined with the fact that 10 monsters
are popping out this is going to be a
hard fight I'm going to curse which
means I might not be able to cast spells
and there's lightning storm going on but
if I win the fight I'm getting a ton of
items so I'll try opening it thankfully
the curse oh look am i silenced no I
just elemental weakness that's right i
was trying to cast the wrong skill okay
yeah sorry i was perfect I'm like damn
it I'm silence what I wasn't so I
managed to call the monsters relatively
easily because I'm high level and out
dropped these items here oh dear Lord so
it's quite a lot of stuff in this
particular chest has it because of the
quantity bonus so the key thing about
these chests though is that they're a
great way to have a fight associated
with finding more stuff and because they
get model and you can actually reroll
the mods so if i just spawn a chest so i
make a chest as a strongbox it would
spawn 10 monsters I fight them and I get
some items that's the default form the
players are going to want to try to get
better items out of that and to get
better items they're going to need to
advance to the chest so here's the items
i got from a typical chest there's a
relatively small amount because it
wasn't a hard fight so if i spawn a
chest here and i try using some currency
on it if i use an orb alchemy it makes
it rare and then i say oh I don't like
it I'm going to use a chaos orb or just
click on it by mistake
cuz I'm failing at the control sir yeah
but the point is you can use your
currency to reroll the challenge so if
you find something on there that's
really hard in this case it was worth it
i got a unique item and three rares so
the mods on that certainly increased the
value of the chest now typically
people's characters won't be as pimped
out as this one as the fights will
actually be really however we're
demonstrating on a relatively powerful
character but the cool thing is as
players go through the levels that
punctuated by the ability to choose the
difficulty of their encounters and it
also lets them waste their currency
which is something we love they're going
to sink currency into making the chest
just try to see what they get out and in
the case of this it's worth it I paid
one alchemy and I got three raised in
unique item that's a good trade in many
cases it won't be so we're interested to
work out of the players can find the
sweet spot of how much currency to sink
into these chests right there's also a
hardcore league that one's called
invasion now I don't have a demo of that
one handy because there's a little bit
harder to show but the basic thing
behind invasion is we want players to
die more and the way that we do that is
by having monsters from other areas of
the game invade in two different ways so
when you're playing the first thing
you'll notice is that there are monsters
in the areas that don't normally belong
there borrowed from elsewhere in the
game and by by itself that provides some
variety but the scary thing is the fact
that we've also guested in invading
unique monsters so there's no an
additional boss in each area when
they're very powerful ones part of the
pool of the 60 bosses that we've added
to the game for the side areas and for
this purpose and these bosses well
you've got to be careful when you run
into them because they're using advanced
combinations of skills and you're just
not going to expect them and not going
to know how they synergize with the
monsters in the area so a person playing
in the invasion league gets all of the
content of sacrifice of the val- these
chests that are specific to ambush but
has monsters that pros potentially much
harder challenges than normal randomly
in areas and this fits the criteria of
trying to design hardcore leagues that
just slaughter the players as much as we
can because that's what hard was about
getting people to start playing the game
for the scratch
so Chris what have we missed we've gone
over so much on sacrifice of the valley
i wonder what have we missed that we
haven't touched on yet there's going to
be something there are three topics left
okay the first one is there's a new
Grand boss fight that goes at the end of
the game now we don't want we don't want
to spoil us at all so we're not going to
show any of that content I'm really
sorry but this this content is something
we've reserved for the players they're
going to discover its they have to work
out how they open that area hint it's
got something to do with something I
showed earlier and alluded that so
that's helpful oh we watch the video so
I fight that's so they can they can find
a way to spawn at Ceres area and they
can find a way to kill her and it's
going to be hard and that's awesome the
second thing to do with this the second
thing to do with this is that we're
actually running a competition for the
first 50 people to kill at xerion each
of the challenge leagues so if you're
playing an ambush or invasion which is a
fresh start the first 50 players to kill
her in that area are going to get an
exclusive microtransaction effect which
they can only get from this challenge so
it's of the quality of something that
we'd normally sell it'll probably valve
thing probably lots of blood will see
what it looks like but it's basically
going to be something that's a status
symbol showing that you're one of the
first 50 players to collect 0 and you
promise you won't be selling that later
that's right that's okay good so it's a
status symbol is essentially priceless
so that's going to be really interesting
because it's it's only applies to the
challenge leagues so you have to
actually play through the game and find
out Syria and people going to be really
going without sleep to do this I suspect
so there are two other features in the
expansion that we like to talk about as
well the first one is introducing an
improved cutthroat league this is a
league where players are able to invade
each other's instances and kill them and
steal their items and it's only
appealing to a small percentage of
players wear those players absolutely
love it and our pledge basically is to
iterate on this with the players getting
feedback throughout this for months
season so we're going to run events of
different lengths and we're going to
iterate on making sure that the balance
is right that they have the features
that they require in that league and
it's something that we because we don't
have a thousand players in our office to
test it out we really have to involve
the community with it but it's a major
priority and we're going to start
running the events through soon after
the patch is deployed finally the last
thing to note is that there's now a
free-for-all PvP arena which is
basically a no rules no rewards PvP
place that you can go to bash up on
dozens of other players
and something players have been asking
for because they want a non structured
pvp mode so it's easy for us to add and
therefore we've delivered her a great
well that's the feature list chris is a
lot we have a lot we have a lot to look
forward to and when it when is all this
content going to be dropping for all of
the peeps it's on match 5th US time at
1pm oh wow so soon yep pretty soon it's
going to be exciting it is exciting i'm
i'm now looking forward to getting back
in my haven't played path of exile for a
short while so it seems like a good
reason to go back to me well we've tried
to structure it so it's lots of content
to come back to and also new leaks to
compete in so it's a fresh playing field
excellent well thank you so much for
stopping by i'm looking forward to
playing path of exile's sacrifices the
vowel thanks for making it and everybody
out there thanks for tuning in and I
guess we'll see you soon on another
episode of not playing thanks